c'est non non
bonsoir bonsoir on nous parle
bonsoir on nous dit qu'il est question
de remplacer l'annuaire des ptt par
l'ordinateur
si cela était nous regretterions
vivement la disparition de l'annuaire
des ptt
car lanières des ptt à l'instar du
teckel ou du fox-terrier était le
meilleur ami de l'homme les services
rendus à l'homme en effet par l'annuaire
des ptt étaient multiples tout d'abord
l'annuaire des ptt était très jolie en
tant que sous verre comme nous allons
montrer maintenant voyez que je prends
un annulaire des adultes et un vert un
charmant bouquet
et comme le constate ans et du plus bel
effet d'autre part l'annuaire des ptt
était un outil de travail indispensable
[Musique]
tous les annuaires n'était pas
indispensable à l'homme il faut bien
l'avouer seul et c'est important
seul l'annuaire du dessous était
indispensable à l'homme
voyez vous c'est celui ci c'est toujours
celui dont on a besoin
celui de lucho mais il n'ya pas que la
nuit est douce
[Musique]
non maintenant faire le 12
pour mieux répondre à raison qu a pas de
cause
[Applaudissements]
laluque
tout l'avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le numéro que vous avez demandé n'est
pas en service actuellement
mais regrettons de ne pouvoir donner
suite à votre appel c'est non non
[Musique]